P data s West anyway um P data is um
what launch by num Focus for more than
10 years ago uh num Focus supports open
source software um mainly for scientific
applications um there's many packages
you probably know and work with like
pandas or M plot lip or numpy so there
there's many many many um and psych it
learn it's also like important that open
source gets financially supported and
focus is a US Foundation who actually
does that and we also have a code of
conduct for us it's very important that
we are um a professional Community uh
but we also a professional Community
from with many different backgrounds and
so we uh don't not tolerate any
harassment in community members in any
form and if you have any questions just
go to the website if you face any
problems or you don't feel uh you feel
uncomfortable just speak to one of the
organizers uh and if you want to report
something anonymously you can also go to
the num Focus website to do
that um yeah Meetup so I mentioned so we
are here p z West pwest was actually the
aftermath of Pyon de 208 because the
Pyon de had like a a pataa track as well
and then Pyon de moved on and became
Pyon D in Pata Vin and we felt here okay
why not launch local pataa chapters and
we thought it's a bit it's a bit silly
to have p hadberg p Manheim p k since
everything is really connected here so
we found founded P data West as a Meetup
for multiple cities and we are just like
in the middle of that so there's many
meetups there's 200,000 members
according to meetups there's more than
200 groups in 76 countries so there's a
lot going on uh and yeah you're also
part of that one part that's why we also
try even to stream the meetups is um uh
we want to share the knowledge presented
at the meetups what especially also like
the conferences there's also P data
conference big up p conferences and we
put them on YouTube for everybody to
learn
from uh so P data zest uh is yeah as I
mentioned idleberg house Manheim in
January we will include hibron as well
and we have grown by more than 300
members since this spring we're now
1,700 members now um if you want to host
the Meetup you can um or your company
you can just ping us if you want to know
more about it uh there's also link later
where you can find find out more um and
of course your contributions with the
talk or lightning talk are always
welcome as well so um and that's a form
just to submit lightning talk so um we
couldn't do that without sponsors and
hosts so I'm very happy to be here at
bla blonda is one of the cool kids in
open source and early machine learning
because they were actually giving like
multiple talks at the first Pata Berlin
in 2014 already so
uh and uh so thanks for that and also
Kik for supporting organization and no
food not not the food this time and
that's F sorry copy paste food is on
Blue Yonder and the drinks so complaints
also to Blue
Yonder so sorry yes I'm blue Peter you
want to introduce bit about blue yonder
yeah I keep it very short because I
think we have a talk also going a little
bit of the history um so what is Bland
basically we have been a startup founded
here in house for by Professor F so spin
off um from the University we started
early on with machine learning using
data science when it still was
statistics done by physicians so um
early on what we are now doing we had a
long journey um we have been bought by
us company the US company has been
bought by Panasonic so we are now in an
Enterprise with I don't know 50,000
people what we are still doing here in
car is machine learning with lots of
Open Source tools and where very really
proud is that we are really driving
business critical infrastructure so
Supply chains yeah that's a supermarket
Saints Beres basically every product
that you see in here yeah runs through
our system on a day-to-day basis and we
all do this with machine learning get
you a little bit more Jacob later what
we also do Yeah you mentioned it and I'm
very proud of this so I'm with this
company now for 10 years and each year
for 10 years now we have been sponsoring
yeah even events like oros ccii
europython Pyon py data I think we have
first met at a karoke 10 years ago so
that's where our history goes back so
that's also something I'm always proud
so we heavily use all this open software
um but we also try to give a little bit
back yeah with Community work with
funding some of the activities um that's
probably where I'm much more proud of
than than just doing the business so
thanks for being here um yeah looking
forward yeah thank you and thanks for
your support
yeah so uh yeah this is myself so I'm
partner at Kix week we are Boutique
consultancy and also we do uh um from
everything from strategy to
implementation and implementation we do
exclusively with open source and helping
to organize uh community events is our
way of contributing back
and yes yeah contact us so there's also
a LinkedIn group or um if you want to
join that if you don't know that just
just go here it's a closed moderated
group so no spams no recruiters so it's
just like for to connect the um local
community here uh then that's the agenda
that's already outdated uh because we
are running late but you get the idea so
let's um we have a talk by johannas uh
in in in a minute about DIY python
debugger then we have the networking
break with Cod Pizza because it's
already ordered right um
no and then after after the
break yakob will tell us more about 10
years of AIML driven products at scale
here and we have uh three lightning
talks I think there's the third one now
and yeah and then networking in and you
get the idea I think so yes we have two
lightning talks soam you're around yeah
wonderful then I will rent about python
in Exel and then there's python bar Camp
um lighting talk as well and we have
short Community announcement if you like
pizza you can still make your way to
Hamburg to python pizza and if you
cannot make the way to to Hamburg
tomorrow you can also join remotely um
python Pizza is a one track conference
only with 10minute talks and pizza and
it's very enjoyable I'll be there so and
if you like Duna you can of course go to
Berlin to the BCC to this wonderful
location uh here at the BCC so we have a
10 years anniversary of uh Pata bin to
celebrate uh it's it's going to happen
in April um save the date uh we're just
launching the cfp so we're just like
setting everything up so program
committees already working so if you
want to be um notified about when the
cfp opens and other things and ticket
sales subscribe to
newsletter and I promise you tickets
will be sold out really quickly that
last
here so we always as I said we have a
call for speaker so if you want to give
a talk just reach out uh we can also
help you mentoring if you're not sure or
give you some tips if it's your first
talk so work first talk first time
speakers are explicitly welcome as well
and uh and giving a talk is a way great
way also to contribute back to the
community also side note meetups are
excellent to practice for big conference
talks like for big conferences like this
yeah so just a hint so okay slido I
mentioned if you want to ask questions
you'll find that also on the M mid up
page and now I would like to welcome
Johannes to give a talk about um the
python D debugger I'm really excited and
let the the the the HDMI gots with us so
we switch now
here you
go
yeah oh yeah
The Benchmark is actually in M the first
P he want to do live coding since
Wireless down video anybody
notic yeah the last time that I did live
coding I was at the K and tar and I did
a live coding of C++ in front of a Java
audience that
well so yeah um and and regarding Pizza
um the worst Pizza that I ever ate to
the me was in Milan they had the most
rubbish pizza and the best one was in in
in Mich so if you ever want to do a talk
at open well you they have good
pizza
um funny um I hope screen mirroring
Works uh I hope the screen is not
mirrored okay um yeah I'm I'm Johan bber
um and I sometimes give talks it's my
last talk this year
yay I can really recommend doing talks
and here being here is really a great
honor um just write people may and
saying Hey I want to do a talk do you
have time and they will give you a time
so and now I'm here uh so um I'm I'm
talking about debugging uh when we talk
about debugging we we essentially like
we're essentially backing this is like
the first buck it's actually a moth from
the 50s so it's I don't know why it's
not called the moing but I know they
they weren't biologists they were
mathematicians and physics and know how
they are to the out B that's the first
bug they found um it was stuck on relay
and caused a short circuit but we need
debugging not just because we sometimes
have moths in our kitchen but also
because um when debugging is the process
of removing software bucks then
programming must be the process of
putting them in according to Edgar D and
I can agree who doesn't know like when
when you write your first snippet of
code and it works the first time you
call it and you're like that can't be
right there must be a back where is this
back and you search like a bu for for
half an hour and then you're like there
isn't any bu in it so um it it helps
when you then make a small tiny mistake
and just put a bug in we nowadays have I
I we can just tell they I make a small
bug in it so you feel good because you
found the back um essentially that I'm
so essentially um I I also wrote the
small small um uh program um for for the
so it's called counter. P it counts the
Cod lines and the first time I run it it
didn't work of course um because it's
code um it printed out null and I'm like
okay I know that this code has to have
at least a few lines then i' run it um
across with another utility and it was
26 lines so yay there's probably a back
in it so let's look at the code so um
that behind me is like the main method
that's not fancy so but for a little bit
of bragging the you know my pip prob who
of you use knows my pie H yay um I was
the supervisor of the bachelor's unit
that implemented the that implemented
type checking for match case uh which I
found quite neat so we use this feature
all the time um when we look further
because the main method isn't really
important it does che TT say is it
distinguish between the line and the
help command um we have the Cod C lines
just accept the path and then ask every
line of the code hey is this a code line
and then we have to is code line above
that returns all in for strength any
ideas what went
wrong nobody good uh let's let's ask a
debugger because debuggers are your
friend they are great tools um and we
probably use them more than any other
tool who of you used the de buer
before who didn't use a debugger before
yeah the funny thing that the last time
I did the talk on on related to Java on
this topic uh there was some some young
man in the audience and I asked him
later why don't you use a debug and he
was like I'm just here to get a boogie
place my my father tracked me here to to
look for a company to make uh to to to
work at but apparently uh debugging um
is is a cool skill set it belongs to
your toolbox like testing and profiling
um and no good programmer can do without
um I usually talk about profiling um I'm
yanana beberg working at Submachine um
when you're from P space you probably
don't know that much about Java but we
are like the third biggest contributor
to the open sh so the leading runtime um
and it's one of the cool many cool open
source projects of sap um and so going
on from this um yes we could use an
existing leuger and just place a break
point in this method because there might
be a bug in it but that would be
lame it would be so there are no Rock
signs so Follow Me Down the Rabbit Hall
and we create our own using two
different apis um uh I did this just
because I was procrastinating before
another talk so yay um and it's now a
five part series that you can find on my
blog you find all the information on the
last slide too so you can read all about
it the long version and all the code is
MIT license so so private um so now now
in questions when I when I work on Java
usually like program C++ and python to
work on Java but uh to work on the jvm
the jvm understands the concept of break
points I can tell the jvm hey please set
the breako somewhere do you know does
anyone of you know whether the cpython
interpretor knows about the concept of
SP
points no okay what it does yes it it
doesn't have because um why should it um
the C python interpretor is pretty basic
compared to the jvm the jvm has a Chet
and everything and um and um the uh and
the cpython just has a simple in par
look um any ideas how we could Implement
a debugger what's the simplest way of
like implementing a debug bugger when we
allow or implementing break points when
we allow that we can modify the code I
need
use yeah we we we can just do anything
it's python we can like import
anti-gravity and
refly yes of course that's what we can
do uh we can do it in the beginning of
the line because usually we at a breako
the breakpoint is executed before the
line I hope so um and so we have this
method um and what this method
essentially does it checks is that break
point at the at the line in this file if
yes Michelle and that's essentially
interrupting the program and we can then
in the Shell like for example check
what's the value of line what's the
value of other local variables but the
problem is where do we get file on line
from the idea is here we use a method
that's called this. get frame and the
underscore here means that it's not
really defined in the python standard of
a way but it's in cpython implementation
detail and when you ask other um python
inators like pipie they tell you in the
documentation hey it might be a terrible
idea to use it it might compromise the
performance but we're debugging so we
don't care anyway um and what this does
um it returns us frames of our stack so
in our example we have the main method
this called count Cod lines is cod line
and then we have this dbg dbg call and
what we then have um this doget Frame
zero gives us the top frame but that's
not really interesting because we need
like the the frame below so we ask it
for the for not the topmost but the
frame below with like get frame one and
the cool thing is we get loads of
information from this so we get for
example the line number we get the local
variables like hey what's the value of
line we get the file name we get the
code object we can even like obtain um
the documentation of this method which
is pretty neat and we can use this to
implement um our debug function properly
so we ask it for the top frame and then
we get the line we get the file and then
that's essentially it
[Music]
um and at break point is quite also
simple uh in our simplest example when
we just want to set one single break
point we just check whether hey is the
file this counter fall and this is line
is a line six and so off to the demog
gods um we have this here um we place
the dbg here
and what we have have our implementation
is quite simple as you see here and then
if everything
goes if everything goes right then we
can just run it can can everyone see the
code below or is it too
small
good um so we see it we we hit the
counter and then we opening a shell uh
python is really cool because we have
lots of cool libraries and one of them
is B python so I don't have to
reimplement the Shell myself so we can
just ask for the value of line and ask
some questions and so on and thereby can
obtain the course of the of the problem
we can just quit and we're done and we
can also like continue and the next time
is code line it's also open and that's
quite simple the the main problem is um
it's not that great because we have to
write a check every time and it's quite
M yes we can instrument our Java uh we
can instrument our python code
but yeah we we have ipis for this we
have computers that do this so any ideas
how we can automate
this yeah we if if nobody has an idea I
have one it's called set sis. set trace
the idea is that we pass to sis. set
trace a Handler um and this Handler gets
P the the frame we saw the information
that we get before um and we get an
event an event is some an event could be
call line return exception op code
in theory but in practice it's just for
this Handler that we pass here it's just
call so we this Handler called it every
um at every invocation so it's called
here for example with the frame with the
call and then an argument that that we
can ignore here and then later um the
Handler is called for the is code line
frame and that's quite neat um and if
you want if if you check out the Cod
later you can see that we can simply
implement is simply print in the Handler
like hey this event call came for the
method Main and so we get information on
all the um methods that we called but
that's bit boring we not yet at the
point where we like checking line so
what we do um we look closely again on
the documentation um and see that the
type of the Handler is a bit more
complex so what we what it returns is
not just like a none but it returns
either none or um a callable so it
returns itself a Handler that's called
for every return um exception and um
line and that's pretty cool because we
can use this to implement um our example
from before and um here again uh I just
printed like the line in the inner
method um in in the inner hand line we
can see clearly that we can in get
information here can get like the the
lines the returns um and that's and
that's pretty neat because that allows
us to alterate this task of like running
something at every line and that's what
we're doing you see here again the code
from before um that was just the thing
that we implemented H implemented
directly manually and so what we do we
change the name Tada uh that's the magic
of clicking forward and then we check is
this really a line event because we
we're currently ignoring R return events
and also exceptional events because
we're only like interested in the sing
line events and that's all the code
didn't change it's we we change only
like two lines and that's it and that's
our first working debugger yay and it's
if I can show you if I can show you
it's I think it's set it's yeah it's
it's thing so that's that's actually
what what I wrote here it's like the
inner method is like you've seen before
um and the only thing that I'm doing
additionally is just checking that we
are really in the code that we are um in
a file that we're interested in um so
that they don't print so many internal
events so we can now search for this if
it
works so yeah um we were in the back
Bond at line six and then we can check
like the line and when we look at our
code that's here the line we can even
look into the frame information because
I pass in the Shale the frame object we
can see a clearly where it is it's in
the escod line and then we can also just
casually look where the bug is and some
of you might have noticed that like this
should return false and we can and so we
can split it into parts and the thing
is this line is not a space line so this
was the bug um we can fix it it's not
part of my debugging demo but you can
easily fix it that's the power of
debugging just at a single breakpoint
and you're fine and then when we uh
close it we come again at is C line and
because we call this method a few times
as you see here we're at a different
line um
and so that's that's that's pretty cool
because that's like a functioning PR
that's like a function debugger in like
203d lines of python code and that's the
only language I know of where it's so
fast to develop a debugger from scratch
any questions till
now anything that's unclear good so um
the problem here is um we usually want
to configure these things because we
don't want to hardcode our debugger
um to use it on other applications um
and so we make it configurable that's
quite easy we just have a set of um
break points and we just check hey is
this F and line does this have a break
point there and that's all um
uh and that's and that's all um so we
can then add a simple method that just
inserts a breakpoint in this breakpoint
set um and then we have a custom with
have custom breakpoints and the cool
thing is we can add with a with just two
more lines we can add conditional
breakpoints so for conditional
breakpoints in the add breakpoint method
we just evaluate the condition and and
that's really cool because from when it
come from java and there's nothing like
an evil fun an eval function um so
that's pretty cool that that we have
this here um now uh the only missing
feature that that I probably use use a
lot um is single stepping um the thing
here single stepping is this step one
line further thing and that's pretty
simple to implement because when we
again look at the stacks step out is
just checking at breakpoint hey are we
at um we we're just overloading at break
points so we're just extending it so to
step out we just check that we are like
in the top frame we we store the frame
that we were here and then we check hey
are we at the frame um that lies Below
on the St that's fine the single step or
the step over is also pretty simple we
just check that like um we are in the
same frame but at a different line
number step into same frame here but the
top frame is different um and that's all
it's just like 10 10 more lines of code
um but another question do we get line
events for every line in every function
of our code with this debugger any
ideas or do we want to get line events
for every
function any
use yeah of course that that yes we we
shouldn't but for every other function
is it is it good to get line events for
every other function
see the problem here is it sounds like
confusing because like
why should we get line events for
example for the con Cod lines function
when we only set a break point in is cod
line but the problem is here consider um
we we have again Handler we returned the
the line fun the the line Handler and
then on top we are there and now the
user comes to the Glorious idea to do
something like setting a break point in
his Cod line and he sets the break point
to in in the count Codine lines method
now the problem is when we didn't return
here an inner Handler line Handler um
then we can't accept break points here
so we get break points everywhere so we
um want to return the line Handler for
every function where the user possibly
could set a break point and if the user
is a debugger developer he probably also
wants to set a break point in the
debugger because I can tell you
debugging a debugger is not a good idea
I did it essentially you you just get
down to print F debugging because um
it's it's just far easier and but your
mind blows like it's like profiling a
profiler and yes I did this too and it's
funny
um yeah
did what I do for work is like a fixed
box in Java so um I fixed the null pter
exception in the debugger so I had the
debug so I had an IDE like intell
running in a debugger debugging it and
that that was that was just nice um so
essentially that's the that's the
problem and any problems with this like
any problems with
getting uh with with getting uh with
with returning a line Handler for every
function can you any ideas what what
could be problematic why don't we want
to like be this
situation yeah so so so when so the the
question was like operation level um
break points but that's easy we can just
in the line Handler return the Handler
um
uh but that's the last level of handless
so main problem is here performance so
essentially we're checking at every line
whether there is a break point and yes
we can optimize it um we can we we can
of course make at breakpoint faster
that's simple we just implement it like
probably with a siton extension and
everything um but the main problem is
we're still getting a call for every
line so um the performance of our of
debug application really depends on this
and is really deterior deteriorated
that's especially important if you have
like set a single break point somewhere
and still we get um our handls called
for every line and that's and that's not
that great so one of the ideas is to add
a new API and uh C pess so somebody um
added a new API and the cool thing is
it's probably the first talk on this new
API I at a meet up because uh the API is
like added in 3.12 um and it's out there
since October and as far as I know no
none of the major debuggers uh supported
yet there are proposals for the python
command L debugger that also like in
pyrum uses in the back end to to support
it but it's not yet in so so this is
really fresh out of the oven um if you
want to know more the the chap
the pep is really readable the python
enhancement proposal just go to the link
that I
um got there um and they can really
recommend reading Pyon enhancement
proposal they usually theyve usually um
good examples in them and you can learn
a lot um so what Mark Shannon did he
created this python enhancement proposal
like two years ago it's called low
impact monitoring for cpython that is
usable for like doing coverage doing um
debugging doing profiling tools I'm
focusing here on the debugging Port but
I might do something on profiling in the
future but because that's like the area
that I work um on in the jvm so the idea
is here that it's not just like the
single API where where you just return
where you just pass Handler but you
actually um have a proper API where you
can configure stuff and where you also
support multiple tools so um this whole
thing live lives in Z monitoring um and
you have different events also like line
events like method like function St
events and what you first do you have to
get tool ID the tool ID there are six
possible IDs but um a few of them have
names for example the debugger ID
because usually you don't want to like
attached two
debuggers it's just something that
debugger developers do but that's
possible also now that wasn't possible
before which which I find pretty neat um
so you first register the tool the idea
is here that this method just checks
like hey has someone else registered and
if yes I I show you an exception and you
register with a name so it's easier to
debug later um and then you register
call back so before we had a call back
for like everything um but here you
registered call backs for specific tool
and also um for specific event so for
example here we we register line Handler
and the line Handler looks this way so
it gets past the code like our code
object that's the thing that when you
have a function object and look into the
property underscore uncore code uncore
uncore that's that's what you get here
and then the line and then we also
register a start Handler cback so
essentially we're getting here also the
code object not the frame as before we
have to get the frame if you want to
have more information
we um via sis. getf frame but we saw it
before so what we then also want to do
is we want to enable all the start
events um so all the um all the methods
what we saw previously like the call
events are here called the P start
events we want to enable all for every
um for for every uh method of of your
function um but we can later also set
local events so we have now the
distinction between like events that are
globally active and then we can
additionally enable local events per
code object so per function and that's
pretty neat so we can later somewhere
later even if the function is currently
running and that's the cool thing we can
enable this um uh and the set of events
like per function is is the union of the
globally set events and the locally set
events and the thing is is well the
question that that you might be asking
is what's first so what can we do
without thinking about it and what's
first is reg just call and like get tool
these these simp and other GTO methods
rather fast methods like set local
events so we can do the these
essentially anytime and also like deep
in the C for methods that are already
currently called and they will
retroactively added which is PR neat and
slow uh setting globally
um but that's not a problem because um
the uh python enhancement proposal tells
us that for cpy in implementation both
methods are reasonably fast when you do
them before all the major modules um are
added the idea how this is implemented
is is quite quite easy so essentially
what we did before we had this like um
check is there a prak point if not Al so
the DB key function that we added in
front of every line so what our um cpy
interpretor is doing it's it replaces
the bite code so what it does it
replaces every it replaces the star bite
code of every line with an instrument
with an instrumented bite code um and in
this instrumented bu code it stores what
bu code was there initially before but
in this instrumented bu code it just
checks like hey um uh it it just calls
the Handler so is there Handler that and
then call Handler and that is pretty
neat because it's far more performant
than before because before it called
back into our python code to check hey
should it really go into this should I
really break but here um we reduce it to
checking this only at the lines of the
methods where we actually set a break
point and that's the last demo for the
day
um not the last but like the the last
small demo um so
what you see here is is what you do in
the beginning we do as I told you we set
the events and then we have our
breakpoint data class
um and what we then have here um the
thing is it's it's what's a bit
difficult is that um we usually want to
give the user the the ability to just
say hey uh we to just a in this file at
line six at a break point um and so uh
we have to do like checking when we get
like a code object in we have to check
hey is this do we have a break point
that belongs to this and that's and what
we're essentially doing we we're getting
from this code object the first line and
last line and checking for a breakpoint
that lives in between um and we can of
course optimize this um and there are
more ideas that's something that that
you'll see in my blog posts but yeah so
this is then file functional profile
that's uh debuger that's far more
performance so because we're only
calling these line events for um this
dis Handler for the methods we really
want to um it's far fast I didn't do any
performance measurements yet but I would
assume that it like speeds It Up by by
magnitude and that makes our life as
python debuggers far easier I hope um um
other tool developers will use it soon
um and also makes like doing traing
profiles easier so I think it's a good
way forward and I hope that there is
some progress in in making it even
faster um so putting it all together we
can write a real debugger because you
saw like this debugger that we had
didn't have like single stepping and
anything so
um I also and I hope it works wish me
luck yeah uh
because everything breaks then um that's
a proper debugger that like runs the
file in the context of the debugger and
so um uh for for those of you who know
pigments pigments also allows to to show
code on the command line to highlight
there so here we have the first break
point we want to give users the ability
to set some break points so the first
line of of that's executed from the
program we usually just start the
debugging shell um and so we have this
here and what we can do is we can break
we can break it fun um and so what we
can do here is we can even add
conditions so it's just a python shell
so it has autoc completion and
everything so uh we can just say hey
when the line starts with KNE place
place only stop there and then we can
um con continue and what what you then
see that that this debugger with a bit
of code gives us like the condition and
also um tells us hey there's the break
point and here we are in the in the code
then we can lo to check the line and
also get like show the whole file other
things and the cool thing is also we as
I told you stepping out is is pretty to
implement yay we can also do step out
and step in
and
um here we are in debug and if you look
into the code that's like around 700 800
lines of code um we have here the
question should we should we stop as a
single step and it's pretty easy we we
just check um when we are in step over m
is the frame the same as the the time
where we where we talk where we called
single step and then when we're stepping
into um we always saying like yes uh
because it's always the next line and
then when we're stepping out um we're
checking for an event return because
when we get an event return um we know
that we're going out of this function
and then just check the frame above but
so um that's all here um it's already on
GitHub you can just use it it's MIT
license so do with it what you want um
and if you have any questions there just
write me on LinkedIn on Twitter wherever
you want um and remember the debug is
really interesting and that you should
know your tools so please if you have
some time just just look into how
debugging works and also how like your
test framework of choice works and also
like how profiles work because I feel
like that many
developers take these tools as given and
be like yeah that there are some tools
someone else is like working on and that
works so long till the tool like has
problems and then it's cool because then
when you know how debugger works like in
theory then you can debug the debugger
and contribute something back to the
community and maybe give a talk at this
cool Meetup here and with this you can
find me on Twitter at parm nerd I block
every two every one or two weeks on the
topic Rel like to profiling and
debagging at mostly nerdness my team is
at speet Submachine and Submachine AO
and you can find all the um information
about the to um about my my blog here um
there's the article series and I have
cool stickers with the logo of my team
so just go a few stickers and thank
you
yeah thanks a lot johanes uh the smell
of pizz is in here so is it okay if we
move question to the break of course the
the last time that I did this I did two
weeks ago I did also talk and it went
longer than expected because the person
before me talked along so I I'm
experienced with eating pretty cold
pizza so let's go to the pizza thank
you one thing so uh I I hope I sorted it
out